ion hery Ali's Journey has been
legendary I've been following her story
for about two decades now I read her
book Infidel when it came out then I
read the Caged virgin I was already
familiar with the short film she made
with Teo van go submission that film
cost van go his life it would have been
very easy for ayon to back off of Islam
after losing her friend but she didn't
she started rolling with the new
atheists and went after Islam even
harder then after being one of the main
figures in the new atheist movement for
many years in 20123 she announced that
she'd become a Christian so she went
from Muslim to atheist to Christian
that's a pattern we're going to be
seeing again and again in the near
future and now Aon has become the
prophet of common sense to a western
world that has lost all touch with
common sense in the speech she just gave
at the art conference in London Ian
spent most of her time talking about the
importance of nation states and of
having a healthy sense of nationalism
especially when other forces are at work
trying to destroy Nations and build some
Global
monstrosity but towards the end of her
speech she went in a completely
different direction let's have a look
but I have one more point to add and
it's the most important point of all
the nation state also needs Christian
morality the nation state needs
Christian
morality she didn't get that from her
time with the new atheists I wonder if
she can come up with a powerful analogy
to help clarify her
point in Europe Christianity remains
despite Decades of secularization The
crucial operating system of society
without it the apps don't
work Christianity is the operating
system of Europe without the operating
system the apps don't work Europe
declared war on its own operating system
and now the leaders can't figure out why
everything else stopped
working when I came to Europe in 1992
fleeing a for marriage that was part of
a failed Clan system this was the type
of nation state that I found wealthy
peaceful stable and optimistic but still
rooted in the calvinist and Catholic
Traditions she sought political asylum
in the Netherlands in 1992 and she
describes the nation back then as
wealthy peaceful stable and
optimistic does that sound anything like
Europe
today I had left the chaos of Somalia
and other African nations where I had
lived where tribal ethnic and religious
conflict had made it impossible to
develop a healthy
nationalism what I found in Holland was
truly inspiring to me I found the same
inspiration when I first went to the
United States the Netherlands and the
United States were completely different
from Somalia for some reason what could
be taken for granted in the Netherlands
and the United States was impossible in
Somalia ion was inspired by Western
Nations that's when the new atheists
informed her that Western nations were
great in spite of Christianity not
because of it in fact if they could just
get rid of Christianity the West would
become even
greater but in the past 16 or so years I
have seen on both sides of the Atlantic
a sustained effort to drive Christianity
to the margins of our
society I believe this gamble on
secularism will go terribly wrong it
already
has yeah turns out the new atheists had
absolutely no clue what they were
talking about they were completely out
of touch with reality instead of
improving the West they did massive
damage by attacking the framework of
Western
Civilization every successful nation has
to be based on more than a constitution
and a body of law there must be
transcendental stories that unites
citizens to an ethical as well as legal
code for the West that was the
judeo-christian story of the Bible now
let's have a quick Bible study with
former Muslim former atheist Ayan hery
Ali the biblical understanding of human
sinfulness inspired the concept of
limited state power or rule of law
emphasizing checks and balances to
prevent tyranny Isaiah
33:22 governments are seen as
instruments to maintain order and
justice but not as ultimate
authorities Aon cites Isaiah
33:22 as she talks about the biblical
concept of human sinfulness and how it
led to a system of checks and balances
let's read the verse for the Lord is our
judge the Lord is our lawgiver the Lord
is our King it is he who will save us
what does this have to do with human
sinfulness and checks and balances
interesting story James Madison Founding
Father noticed the three different roles
in governing here judge lawgiver king or
modified for the United States the
judicial the legislative and the
executive God can do all three but human
beings are fallible and corruptible and
power hungry so if human beings are
going to take on these roles the roles
need to be divided up into different
branches of government and there has to
be a system of checks on the power of
these branches so ion is writing the
belief that all humans are created in
God's image Genesis 1:27 underpins ideas
of equal worth human rights and dignity
for all individuals including cluding
the poor and the
neglected Genesis 1:27 so God created
Mankind in his own image in the image of
God he created them male and female he
created them biblical teachings such as
love your neighbor as yourself Leviticus
1918 emphasizes care for others and
fairness in governance Leviticus
19:18 do not seek revenge or bear a
grudge against anyone among your people
but love your neighbor as yourself I am
the Lord if you think this means you
only have to love people in your own
group and not people outside your group
think again same chapter veres 33 to 34
when a foreigner resides among you in
your land do not mistreat them the
Foreigner residing among you must be
treated as your native born love them as
yourself for you were foreigners in
Egypt I am the Lord your God but David
does this mean we have to be nice to
jihadis no this isn't saying you need to
be nice to criminals and people who are
trying to subjugate you this is saying
don't mistreat a foreigner just for
being a foreigner this is about people
like Ayan hery Ali not about people
screaming Allahu
Akbar the Bible's distinction between
God's sovereignity and Earthly author
Matthew
22:21 influenced the Western principle
that the state should not overreach into
matters of faith and
conscience let's read the passage
Matthew 22 starting at verse
15 then the Pharisees went and plotted
how to entangle him in his words and
they sent their disciples to him along
with the herodians saying teacher we
know that you are true and teach the way
of God truthfully and you do not care
care about anyone's opinion for you are
not swayed by appearances tell us then
what you think is it lawful to pay taxes
to Caesar or not this was meant as a
trap for Jesus the Jews were under the
control of the Roman Empire many Jews
did not like paying taxes to their
oppressors so the Pharisees asked Jesus
if it's lawful for a Jew to pay taxes to
Caesar if Jesus says yes he's going to
be in trouble with some Jews they're
going to call him a traitor if he says
no he's going to be in trouble with some
Roman soldiers they're going to teach
him a lesson so how does Jesus
respond but Jesus aware of their malice
said why put me to the test you
Hypocrites show me the coin for the tax
and they brought him a Daenerys and
Jesus said to them who likeness and
inscription is this they said Caesar
then he said to them therefore render to
Caesar the things that are Caesars and
to God the things that are Gods when
they heard it they marveled and they
left him and went away render to Caesar
the things that are Caesars and to God
the things that are Gods so you're
allowed to have dual obligations you can
have obligations to human rulers and
obligations to God but if you pay
attention to what Jesus is saying this
actually ties in with Genesis 127 where
we saw that human beings are created in
the image of God Jesus says show me the
coin for the tax the coin is a Daenerys
this is a Denarius it's got an image of
tiberious Caesar on it Jesus says whose
image is
this
Caesars render to Caesar what belongs to
Caesar
what belongs to
Caesar that which Bears His Image namely
the
Daenerys render to God what belongs to
God what belongs to
God that which Bears His Image namely
you you bear God's image so give the
government the coin and give yourself to
God biblical ethics stress that rulers
and citizens are accountable to a higher
moral law ensuring that government acts
justly and protects the vulnerable
Romans 13
3-4 Romans 13: 3-4 for rulers hold no
Terror for those who do right but for
those who do wrong do you want to be
free from Fear of the one in Authority
then do what is right and you will be
commended for the one in Authority is
God's servant for your good rulers are
supposed to be Servants of God for the
good of the people but if you do wrong
be afraid for rulers do not bear the
sword for no reason they are God's
servants agents of Wrath to bring
punishment on the
wrongdoer these principles collectively
shaped Western values like democracy
human rights and unconstitutional
government that is why my message to you
today and the message of courage. media
is to stress that responsible
citizenship in the west is inseparable
from Christian morality whoa did you
catch that last part responsible
citizenship in the west is inseparable
from Christian
morality responsible citizenship in the
west is inseparable from Christian
morality don't be sad atheist
some of you still don't realize that
you've already absorbed quite a bit of
Christian morality you just bought the
lie that the values you absorbed are
somehow normal for human beings when
they're
not please let's aspire to build or
restore the nation states on which our
security depends and let's ensure that
they run as they used to on that
Christian operating system without which
we can have no moral compass thank
you let's make sure our nation states
run on the Christian operating system
without which we can have no moral
compass this lady used to roll with
Richard Dawkins and Christopher Hitchens
and Sam
Harris if you've been depressed about
the direction things have been heading
you should be encouraged that people
like ayon are breaking the spell she was
held captive by Islam and she got out of
it then she was held captive by the new
atheism and she got out of it if this
woman empowered by the spirit of the
almighty can break those kinds of
psychological and spiritual
chains what business do you have looking
at your city or your country and saying
it's too late for
us moaning and wailing time is
over it's revival time now
[Music]